bonsoir jeudi 11 mars bienvenue dans le
journal de tv 78 l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale en quelques minutes
voici les titres de cette édition
bagarre mortelle entre bandes rivales
meurtre guet-apens contre les forces de
l'ordre ces dernières semaines les faits
de violence commis par des mineurs se
sont multipliés comment expliquer cette
recrudescence nous poserons la question
au sociologue jean michel schloesser
chercheur associé au centre de
recherches sociologiques sur le droit et
les institutions pénales basé à
guyancourt et depuis le 1er mars une
nouvelle crèche a ouvert ses portes à
maurepas la ville parc accueillera à
terme 78 berceau et 29 professionnels
sur place quatre sections pour guider
l'enfant dans sa croissance
et puis direction montfort l'amaury à la
fin de cette édition le château de
grousset va se refaire une beauté
construit en 1815 il vient d'être
racheté par un repreneur qui souhaite en
faire un lieu culturel
avant de développer ces titres la
journée nationale d'hommage aux victimes
du terrorisme elle se déroulait
aujourd'hui c'est la deuxième année que
se tient ce temps de commémoration en
mémoire des nombreux morts et blessés
des attentats dans les yvelines une
cérémonie s'est tenue à la mi journée
dans la cour de la préfecture à
versailles au tour de jean jacques brot
le préfet élus et forces de l'ordre et
notamment la classe de défense du
collège pierre de nos lacs à versailles
une journée à laquelle s'est associée la
ville de conflans sainte honorine
frappés par le terrorisme
le 16 octobre dernier avec l'assassinât
du professeur samuel pâtit le maire de
la commune laurent bros s'était
d'ailleurs aux côtés du président de la
république aujourd'hui pour la cérémonie
d'hommage aux invalides
un collégien roué de coups par plusieurs
personnes devant le collège
charles-péguy enchaîné rocancourt une
adolescente de 14 ans tué par un 10
après un différend avec deux de ses
camarades à argenteuil en seine saint
denis des policiers prise à partie dans
d'un dans un guet-apens à poissy une
scène filmée qui a fait polémique et
deux jeunes interpellés puis des rixe
mortelle entre bandes rivales qui ont
touché le département de l'essonne des
faits de violence grave impliquant des
mineurs se sont multipliées ces derniers
temps dans l'actualité
comment expliquer cette recrudescence
faut-il voir un lien entre toutes ces
affaires
et jean-michel schlosser est avec nous
par visioconférence bonsoir vous êtes
docteur en sociologie chercheur associé
au cesdip c'est le centre de recherches
sociologiques sur le droit et les
institutions pénales il est basé à
guyancourt a priori ces faits que je
viens d'évoquer sondés des faits
totalement différent quoique un lien
peut être fait entre ces différentes
affaires elles sont toutes nées de
différents et pour résoudre ces
différends
c'est finalement la violence auxquelles
ont recours les jeunes c'est quelque
chose de nouveau qui a finalement
toujours existé cette violence chez les
jeunes dont elle a toujours existé elle
et les plages ancien les bandes existe
depuis une trentaine d'années
historiquement nous amène encore
présenté de remonter plus loin le lien
qu'il ya entre les différentes affaires
en face est différente a fait c'est
effectivement la violence d'une part et
si les débordements les délits qui sont
commis par ces bancs de son jeune dans
ma plantation il ya le dernier sondage
une par jour l'année dernière ce qui est
en augmentation champions c'est la
violence elle même devient beaucoup
d'alliances avec apparemment maintenant
l'utilisation parfois d'armato qui
dépasse le cadre que l'on connaissait
avant déjà investi nationaux c'est très
lourd mais des événements de gens il y
en a comment expliquer justement que les
vignes les mineurs sont de plus en plus
violent et surtout alors ce qui marque
dans ces affaires c'est que c'est de
plus en plus jeunes aussi loin oui on a
connu depuis une vingtaine d'années
effectivement un rajeunissement
cette population population de la gang
on voit maintenant des deux mineurs de
11 à 12 ans pour les plus jeunes
violents alors toutes les explications
qui ont été données par les études
sociologique ou d'idéologie qui sont
juste là les parents qui sont très
souvent lendemain démissionnaire l'état
qui est moins mois représentait la
société qui est d'ailleurs être une
immaturité croissante chez ces jeunes
savaient que les services de
renseignement les appelle souvent la
génération sega nintendo sont déjà
complètement déconnecté de la réalité et
qui sont en forme de deux mondes
virtuels monde virtuel dans lequel la
violence n'est pas du coup il n'est pas
du tout inquiétant et qu'ils
considéraient comme une forme normale
des glaciers dans dialogues en quoi la
mairie pour dire il ya toujours de
l'agressivité de la violence ils sont à
la fois dans un monde réel et en même
temps dans un onglet de la violence dont
il est difficile de sortir
et est ce que justement les réseaux
sociaux jouent un rôle aussi dans cette
recrudescence de la violence
à votre avis oui ça ça joue un rôle dans
la recrudescence de la violence pour
pour deux raisons principales la
première c'est que c'est une caisse de
résonance à une forme d'émulation voire
de compétition qui se joue entre
l'entente avec avec des sur les réseaux
sociaux qui leur permettent d'ailleurs
en même temps d'organiser des rencontres
pour des bagarres ou des questions de
sécurité
c'est ça les maintient dans une forme
construite de violence avec ce que
j'appelle le système réside dans la
réalité lorsqu'il a tout donné on sait
ce que ça donne sur un réseau social ou
dans un jeu mais je suis adepte de mort
n'est plus mort et ses prêts ses traits
enfin dans la mentalité et sur la base
de ce qu'ils considèrent nous les
adultes hommes dès juillet je suis dit
on en vit aujourd'hui à donner la mort
selon les derniers chiffres de la
direction générale de la police
nationale il y à une hausse de 24% des
rixes en 2020 en france des rixes qui
sont entre bandes dont 80 % sont issus
de
l'ile-de-france vous lisiez ya pas
forcément plus de violence aujourd'hui
c'est un phénomène qui a toujours existé
ce qu'on peut dire aussi qu'il est
peut-être aussi plus visible avec la
médiatisation forcément qui est donnée à
ces affaires évidemment la chine voit
toujours la joie bien eu ces derniers
jours alors il est vrai que plusieurs
morts ça nécessite égalisation qui donne
bien sûr plus de résonance aux
événements mais encore une fois ce sont
des faits que les policiers légende est
née l'an d'armes aussi bien parce que
cette violence commencent à sortir de
leur mauvaise santé auxquels on avait
l'habitude auparavant les inter urbains
des grandes bulles ses occupants tous
les jours des bandes de stupéfiants sont
à peu à mettre de côté on n'est pas sur
la pêche sur le type domaine bande mais
aurait violents qui sont exacerbées qui
par quoi re non pas des années sans que
les jeunes eux-mêmes sache pourquoi ils
en viennent aux mains
mais cette violence durant 20 ans s'il
n'ya pas véritablement une augmentation
des faits de façon exponentielle
en fait là il ya une augmentation plus
importante oui bon mais on a vu que ça a
touché aussi bien les zones urbaines et
aussi les zones rurales très récemment
avec ce fait qui s'est déroulé dans le
département voisin de l'essonne dans le
petit village de saint chéron en essonne
merci et jean-michel fle sert d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
docteur en sociologie et chercheur
associé au cesdip le cesdip c'est le
centre de recherches sociologiques sur
le droit et les institutions pénales qui
est basé pour le rappel à guyancourt
dans l'actualité un recours déposé par
le collectif qu'ovide 78 de ses
habitants dénoncent l'arrêté préfectoral
entré en vigueur la semaine dernière
celui rendant obligatoire le port du
masque partout dans les yvelines en
extérieur et dans les lieux publics le
collectif juge cette décision
disproportionnée est liberticide et pas
forcément adapté aux milieux ruraux
l'audience pour ce recours en référé
liberté était prévue ce jeudi matin au
tribunal administratif de versailles le
tribunal a rejeté ce recours déposé par
kobe de 78
le maxi bus continuent de faire sa
tournée dans les yvelines ce centre de
vaccination itinérant contre le coc vie
de 19 pour la vaccination contre le
colis 10,9 à la rencontre des habitants
des zones rurales ceux de plus de 75 ans
non couverts par l'un des 13 sites de
vaccination dans le département à chaque
jour d'opération jusqu'à 120 personnes
peuvent être vaccinés par se vaccine bus
est mis en place par la rsc le
département des yvelines
par ailleurs on apprend que le centre de
vaccination situé à versailles ouvrira
exceptionnellement samedi également
l'agencé régionale de santé
elle vient de doter le site de 600 doses
de vaccin il est possible de prendre
rendez vous sur le site d'octo libre
pour rappel la vaccination reste ouverte
pour le moment où plus de 75 ans et aux
personnes souffrant de pathologies
graves ou encore aux plus de 60 ans ou
plus de 50 ans avec comorbidités au
chapitre politique les élections
régionales prévues pour le rappel les 13
et 20 juin prochain laurent saint martin
tête de liste de la république en marche
en ile de france elle ne devrait pas
bénéficier de soutien des conseillers
régionaux modem soutien de la majorité
de ses conseillers régionaux sortants
modem le parti centriste et pourtant
alliés de la majorité depuis les
dernières présidentielles
d'après une information du figaro sept
des 13 élus modem à la région ile de
france soutiennent la présidente
sortante valérie pécresse parmi eux yann
wehrling ancien secrétaire général de la
formation centriste ou encore et
béatrice le couturier président du
groupe au conseil régional
le modem comme lui d y était pour rappel
est un allié de valérie pécresse lors
des dernières élections régionales en
2015 cette dernière elle n'a d'ailleurs
pas
fils y officialiser sa candidature
valérie pécresse on écoute la position
de jean noël barrot député des yvelines
et secrétaire général du modem interrogé
par mélanie poké le modem a travaillé en
bonne intelligence
cinq ans mais aujourd'hui mariant tation
de notre famille politique devrait dans
chaque région à adé stratégie
convergente avec nos partenaires de la
majorité présidentielle est donc
aujourd'hui ce que nous faisons c'est de
travailler à la constitution d'un dans
le projet ont pour l'ile-de-france avec
nos alliés quand marche et d'autres
candidats sont d'ores et déjà en lice
clémentine autain pour la france
insoumise jordan bardella pour le
rassemblement national audrey pulvar
pour le parti socialiste et julien bayou
pour europe ecologie les verts un mode
de transport la ligne est la deuxième
plus fréquenté d'europe avec près de 900
mille voyageurs par jour son terminus
dans les yvelines et à saint rémy les
chevreuse le rer b cristallise les
conflits entre l'entreprise alstom et le
groupe ratp sncf ile de france mobilité
la raison le renouvellement des rames de
la ligne
une histoire en plusieurs épisodes qui
nous est résumé par eléonore sinoquet
c'est un feuilleton qui n'est pas près
de se terminer celui des nouvelles rames
du rer b tout est parti d'un appel
d'offres de la sncf et de la ratp pour
remplacer le matériel vieillissant de la
ligne b du rer pour rappel cette ligne
elle part de saint rémy les chevreuse
dans les yvelines passe par l'essonne
traverse paris puis remonte jusqu'à
l'aéroport charles de gaulle ou bien
jusqu'à mitry claye en seine et marne
l'appel d'offres concernait donc la
livraison de son 46 nouveaux trains
l'offre retenue par la sncf et la ratp
le 13 janvier dernier est celle de
bombardier transport et du groupe
espagnol caf 2,56 milliards d'euros mais
une autre entreprise était aussi sur le
coup alstom débouté la faire se
complique alors lorsque alstom rachète
le groupe bombardier fin janvier début
février ensuite l'entreprise retire
l'offre de bombardier provoquant la
colère du groupement
sncf ratp mais aussi d'ile-de-france
mobilité pour alstom l'offre n'est pas
viable financièrement
de l'autre côté des actions judiciaires
sont envisagées si l'engagement
justement n'est pas tenu par alstom ce
jeudi 11 mars valérie pécresse
présidente de la région ile de france et
donc d'ile-de-france mobilité a même
menacé l'entreprise alstom
elle a notamment déclaré sur bfm
business nous allons avoir une
discussion très ferme avec alstom elle a
aussi rappelé que 25 % du carnet de
commandes d'alstom dans le monde c'était
l'île de france
dans ce contexte très tendu l'engagement
de livrer les nouvelles rames d'ici 2025
sera-t-il tenu rien n'est moins sûr une
très mauvaise nouvelle pour les usagers
du rer b car le matériel vieillissant
occasionnent régulièrement des
désagréments sur la ligne le rer b c'est
la deuxième ligne la plus empruntée du
réseau avec près d'un million de
voyageurs avant la crise sanitaire
la décision d' alstom fait donc craindre
d'importantes conséquences financières
autant pour les exploitants que pour les
usagers la colère des personnels
d'éducation au lycée jean rostand à
mantes-la-jolie depuis le 5 mars une cp
heures entamé une grève de la faim
elle a raison la fermeture de la section
bac pro gestion administration à la
rentrée prochaine cela va entraîner la
suppression de son poste et d'un demi
poste d'infirmière également à la
conseillère principale d'éducation a
reçu le soutien de ses collègues qui ont
mené ce jeudi une opération lycée mort
sur place ils font part de leur
incompréhension dans cet établissement
qui a vu augmenter et dernièrement ses
effectifs d'élèves et deadline fixée à
ce jeudi soir minuit vous avez encore
quelques heures pour formuler vos voeux
sur parcours sup la plateforme
d'orientation post bac et les élèves en
terminale ou en réorientation doivent
s'inscrire et formuler jusqu'à 10 veut
ce ne sera plus possible passé ce jeudi
soir minuit hé les inscrits auront
ensuite jusqu'au 8 avril pour finaliser
leur dossier rédigé des lettres de
motivation environ 1 900 mille candidats
sont concernés par la plateforme
parcours sub 18000 formation y sont
proposées
une nouvelle crèche à maurepas la ville
parc accueille des enfants depuis le 1er
mars programmée depuis septembre dernier
programmé pour septembre dernier les
travaux ont été retardés par la crise
sanitaire la crèche va accompagner les
nourrissons de la croissance dans leur
croissance et leur éveil bixente n'a
rien senti steban la nouvelle crèche
ville parc à maurepas enfin ouvertes des
bâtiments qui accueilleront à terme 78
berceau et 29 professionnels
les parents des enfants déjà présents
semblent déjà conquis par les lieux ça
fait dix jours maintenant qu'on est
entré dans la crèche le retour des
parents est assez positif
ils sont plutôt enchanté par toute cette
clarté cette luminosité et du coup les
cet effet de grandeur aussi découpé en
quatre sections de couleurs différentes
un véritable travail a été effectué avec
l'architecte pour retracer le
cheminement de l'enfance et accompagner
pédagogiquement les nourrissons cette
section de couleur bleue tortue bleue
nous l'avons appelée bull d'éveil alors
pourquoi but de l'éveil parce que c'est
plus spécifiques à une section de bébé
et du coup ils sont dans un contenant
après le bleu vient le vert afin
d'emmener les petits vers leur
développement
arrive ensuite l'apprentissage des mots
et l'affirmation de soi par le jeu pour
la mairie cette nouvelle crèche
s'inscrit dans le cadre d'un projet plus
global
la mairie de maurepas et à l'initiative
d'un grand projet qui s'appelle le
projet génération à la place de la
crèche théo boulot qu'ils étaient plus
dans le centre-ville de maurepas il va y
avoir une résidence services seniors et
nous avons choisi ce lieu qui est une
ancienne école pour y déplacer la crèche
est au boulot c'était justement pour
avoir une très chaud petit peu plus
grande et surtout plus plus moderne
parce que l'ancien datait des années 80
elle était aux normes mais elle était où
elle avait quand même été un petit peu
vétuste parmi les innovations de
l'établissement l'espace nos élèves il
permettra une fois achevé à un
professionnel et un enfant de s'isoler
et se consacrer à l'éveil des sens pour
un moment tout en lumière
en musique la commune de maurepas qui
est en deuil et nous avons appris ce
jeudi la disparition de gérard amon 86
ans le sculpteur c'était un le 4 mars
dernier
l artiste a signé de très nombreuses
oeuvres dans la ville qui décorent les
places et les rues mort pas y est
notamment le combat de chèvre rond point
jean moulin ou jeune fille assise sur le
parvis de la mairie et gérard hamon
avait travaillé de pair avec l'urbaniste
jacques riboud lors de la construction
de la ville nouvelle nous l'avions
rencontré en 2019 dans son atelier
parisien écouter et vous avez signé plus
d'une dizaine d'oeuvres sur cette
commune est mort pas n'a pas fait on lui
parle on a pas moins perdu rang en
comptant les choses puisqu'on a fait
aussi pas mal de musique
vous avez vu que la gent plat à l'hôtel
de ville il ya les musées qui est qui il
ya le cheval de l'hôtel et laisse la
cavalerie la grande cavalerie ha oui hh
ça fait quand même pas mal d'heures que
j'ai fait là bas et l idée ce que vous
me disiez un peu avant qu'on débute
l'enregistrement c'était aussi de créer
un passé dans ces villes nouvelles en
fait c'est ça le concept et le concept
de ribou andorre son côté jeudi curieux
et et il a eu l'idée géniale c'est lui
qui a eu l'idée géniale
il y disait on construit des quartiers
neufs
il faut leur donner une vie immédiate
il faut pas qu'il faut que les échanges
soient retrouvent sur leur passé quelque
part la disparition du sculpteur gérard
amon à 86 ans une cérémonie religieuse
s'est tenue ce jeudi matin dans le 14e
arrondissement à paris
pour refermer ce journal il est
régulièrement sous les feux des
projecteurs le château de grousset à
montfort l'amaury accueil très
régulièrement est des tournages
d'émissions et de films construite en
1815 la bâtisse vient d'être racheté par
un repreneur qui souhaite en faire un
lieu culturel les précisions de mélanie
poké
bonjour trois tournages avec un point
commun le château de brousse et
l'édifice est aujourd'hui vie de
nombreux meubles mais pour une bonne
raison
deux ans et demi de travaux vont être
lancés le château vient de se trouver un
repreneur
il était donc racheter suite à un appel
d'offre qu'on a lancé que sa faim qui a
duré pendant un peu plus d'un an donc on
a fait un appel à propositions pour la
reprise du château et donc qui on a
sélectionné donc une famille française
qui est amoureux de l'art et qui a déjà
investi dans un autre lieu sur paris en
une visite des architectes qui prévu
dernière là on travaille beaucoup ici
avec la drac avec le conservateur il la
bf
donc on a eu la chance de pouvoir
construire un vrai projet avec eux et
donc ils sont partis là je pense à
partir la fin de l'année on va partir
sur des débuts de travaux initialement
fondée en 1815 avec un premier bâtiment
sur les terres de chasse de louis xiv
construit pour la duchesse de chârost et
les racheter en 1938 par charles de
beistegui c'est un château qui a une
particularité c'est très peu de gens
savent que depuis 1950 jusque dans les
années 70 dates de 17 charles domestique
tout le café society parisien venait
faire la fête au château de brousse
c'est ça toujours été privée jusqu'en
l'an 2000 quand la famille décès d'yves
avant de château ces genres les milieux
qui va racheter le château derrière et
qui pendant dix ans va en faire une
restauration et va décider de l'ouvrir
en partie au public
il y a 6 ans des amoureux du château et
d'histoire se lance dans l'aventuré et
créé l'association patrimoine aventure
c'est nous qui avons entre guillemets
initie cette volonté de découvrir qui
était cet ce personnage charles
domestique est de faire découvrir l'
influence qui là encore aujourd'hui sur
l'architecturé le design est donc on a
créé une visite qui permet à chacun de
comprendre la folie de cet homme mais
surtout l' influence sur l'architecturé
le design
le château est classé monument
historique depuis 1993
à l'issue des travaux des artistes
seront accueillis à demeure
on devrait encore d'apercevoir dans de
nombreux
long métrage le site accueille toujours
des équipes de tournage
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]